in other videos we have talked about how
ratification of the u.s constitution to
replace the articles of confederation
was not a slam dunk after the
constitution was drafted during the
constitutional convention in mid-1787
you actually have a significant group of
people who are against the ratification
and we study some of their writings in
another video on the anti-federalist
papers in particular on brutus one which
is the most prominent of them in this
video we're going to focus on the other
side on the folks who are aggressively
advocating for ratification of the
constitution alexander hamilton james
madison john jay were some of the most
prominent of these and they were the
ones that wrote the federalist papers
that were focused on convincing everyone
to adopt the constitution and what we're
going to look at in this video is
perhaps the most famous of the
federalist papers this is federalist
number 10. or at least an excerpt of
federalist number 10 that we're going to
look at right over here it was published
november 23rd 1787 and if you remember
the video on brutus one this is only a
few weeks after brutus one which is now
considered a famous anti-federalist
paper was published so it's right in
this time period right over here where
people are going back and forth deciding
do we ratify this constitution and james
madison published under the pen name
publius and publius is making reference
to one of the ancient roman aristocrats
who overthrew the roman kingdom in the
late 6th century to establish the roman
republic so one way to think about it is
he is viewing himself and the other
federalists as trying to establish a
strong republic this is in comparison to
brutus which we see as the pen name for
some of the significant anti-federalist
papers and brutus played a significant
role in the assassination of julius
caesar to keep him from corrupting the
republic ending the republic and turning
it into an empire
but now let's read this excerpt of
federalist number 10 and as i read this
keep in mind some of these ideas these
flavors of democracy that we have talked
about in other videos does madison in
federalist number 10 does he seem
pro-participatory democracy or
anti-participatory democracy does he
seem to think that pluralism is a good
idea or a bad idea and is he more
pro-elite democracy or anti-elites
running a democracy to the people of the
state of new york and like brutus one
it's addressed to the people of the
state of new york because one new york
was a significant state and he's trying
to convince them in this case to support
the u.s constitution
among the numerous advantages promised
by a well-constructed union none
deserves to be more accurately developed
than his tendency to break and control
the violence of faction so
well-constructed union needs to be able
to control the violence of a faction in
fact this is in the title the union as a
safeguard against domestic faction and
insurrection
complaints are everywhere heard from our
most considered and virtuous citizens
that our governments are too unstable
that the public good is disregarded in
the conflicts of rival parties and that
measures are too often decided not
according to the rules of justice and
the rights of the minor party
but by the superior force of an
interested and overbearing majority so
already outlining some of the problems
this problems of faction this problem of
majority rule overrunning minorities or
the rights of the minorities
it is in vain to say that enlightened
statesmen will be able to adjust these
clashing interests the clashing
interests of faction and render them all
subservient to the public good
enlightened statesmen will not always be
at the helm
it may be concluded that a pure
democracy by which i mean a society
consisting of a small number of citizens
who assemble and administer the
government in person can admit of no
cure for the mischiefs of faction
so a pure democracy which is about as
close as you can get to a participatory
democracy madison here is claiming that
it can admit of no cure for the
mischiefs of faction that it doesn't
really help the situation a common
passion or interest will in almost every
case be felt by majority of the whole
and there is nothing to check the
inducements to sacrifice the weaker
party or an obnoxious individual
hence it is that such democracies have
ever been spectacles of turbulence and
contention have ever been found
incompatible with personal security or
the rights of people and have in general
been as short in their lives as they
have been violent in their debts so what
does madison think of participatory
democracies
right he doesn't think too highly of
them he says look a majority is going to
take over and they're going to trample
over the rights of everyone else so
clearly he thinks that a participatory
democracy
not
not
good
a republic by which i mean a government
in which the scheme of representation
takes place opens a different prospect
and promises the cure for which we are
seeking so in his definition of republic
it's a situation where you have the
people being represented by others
the two great points of difference
between a democracy or pure democracy
and a republic are
first the delegation of the government
in the latter to a small number of
citizens elected by the rest so he's
saying in a republic you're delegating
the government to a small number of
citizens elected by the rest
secondly the greater number of citizens
and the greater sphere of country over
which the latter the republic may be
extended so this is interesting because
in brutus one the argument is made that
republics aren't good at ruling over
large territories here madison is
claiming that a republic is better at
ruling over a greater sphere of country
over a greater number of citizens
the effect of the first difference and
so this is the notion of having these
representatives having a representative
democracy is to refine and enlarge the
public views by passing them through the
medium of a chosen body of citizens
whose wisdom may best discern the true
interests of their country and whose
patriotism and love of justice will be
least likely to sacrifice it to
temporary or partial considerations
under such a regulation it may well
happen that the public voice pronounced
by the representatives of the people
will be more consonant to the public
good than if pronounced by the people
themselves so this is really really
interesting because we already saw that
madison is not a fan of participatory
democracy and here he's saying look if
you take the views and pass them through
the medium of a chosen body of citizens
that these people might represent the
public good better than the people
themselves this is really madison being
very pro
democracy
where you have a limited number of
people who are really participating and
he's making the argument that they might
be better at representing the needs of
the people than the people themselves
on the other hand the effect may be
inverted so he is giving some credence
to the other side of the argument
men of factious tempers of local
prejudices or of sinister designs made
by intrigue by corruption or by other
means first obtain the suffrages and
then betray the interests of the people
the question resulting is whether small
or extensive republics are more
favorable to the election of proper
guardians of the public wheel and it is
clearly decided in favor of the latter
so large republics by two obvious
considerations
in the first place however small the
republic may be the representatives must
be raised to a certain number in order
to guard against the cabals of a few and
that however large it may be they must
be limited to a certain number in order
to guard against the confusion of a
multitude so this is really interesting
he says look no matter how large your
republic you're going to need a certain
number of representatives you have too
small then they're just going to be able
to control everything but if you have
too many representatives it's just going
to be confusing
hence the number of representatives in
the two cases not being in proportion to
that of the two constituents you're not
going to keep the same proportion
depending on population and being
proportionally greater in the small
republic it follows that if the
proportion of fit characters be not less
in the large than in the small republic
the former will present a greater option
and consequently a greater probability
of a fit choice so what he's really
saying is in a large republic you're
more likely to find fit and good
representatives than you will in a small
republic once again
he wants people who he considers to be
elite in some way the more educated
whatever you might consider elite to be
for the sake of time i'll leave you
there in this part one video and in part
two we'll see james madison continue to
argue not only for a republic but for a
large republic which the u.s
constitution provides for arguing that
you'll have better people representing
in government and you will also have a
more pluralist society which we'll see
is very different than the view of the
anti-federalists